on
have the uh the most votes in the
balloting he gets the first pick of the
starters and you've checked your sheet
and he's ready to go uh with the first
pick and the 2023 All-Star starters game
I'm going with Joe well in b
[Applause]
order
[Music]
the Eastern Conference player of the
month for both December and January out
of the 45 games he's played 30 plus and
31 of them
okay
Giannis
with a with my first pick
you got it big huh so that means I gotta
get bigger too
but with my first big uh I'm gonna go
with Jason Tatum
foreign
is the youngest Celtic to ever be a
four-time All-Star
and he's on team Giannis all right
LeBron with my second pick
and the 23 All-Stars
I'm going with the wizard AKA young guy
Kyrie Irving
all right
hey Cleveland that was for you
back when he was just a young buck at 21
he was the All-Star game MVP back in
2014. all right Giannis
with my second pick I gotta make sure
he's on stage okay cool okay
who is my second pick as I said before
rising star superstar Morse electric
fire and play in the league John Moran
he tried to sneak one by us in the first
round but now legit he picks John Moran
[Applause]
eighth in the litigan scoring in fifth
and assists with my third pick
[Applause]
I'm gonna go with hookah
Luka dances
he is the League's leading scorer
got 10 triple doubles including a
60-point triple double against the New
York Knicks Giannis
I got him right where I want him I got
him
so this is my third pick
yes okay
with my third pick I'm going with Mr 71
Donovan Mitchell
number nine score in the league and
those 71 came against the Chicago Bulls
in fact it was 71 and then 10 assists in
that game there were just two starters
left up here
LeBron
[Applause]
they already know with my last pick
I'm going with Mr triple double himself
right here Nicola
joking
The Joker and Lowry marketing
with my last thing
outgoing with Larry marketing Let's Go
YouTube
hold up don't go anywhere yet don't
don't go anywhere yet look this has been
uh
this year we've had a very active trade
deadline
and so the question is
are you satisfied with your team or when
you look at the roster and this has
happened before there's been a trade
made
so what are you thinking
for starter or reserve for Reserve
I'm good I'm good too you're good we're
good with the teams you're good yeah and
let me say this where is can you get the
Joker here for one second
Nicola
we just want to salute Nicola and just
tell he's going to be the first player
in the history of the All-Star Game to
be a starter on his birthday so wish him
well at some point today
the stage is set the teams have been
selected you guys can head down
your with your crew
we wish you the best tonight team LeBron
loaded and ready to do their best for
Big Brothers Big Sisters of Utah team
Giannis ready to go for raise the future
there's more than
750 thousand dollars up for grabs for
two very worthy and deserving
organizations and we're just moments
away from it all hope you enjoyed that
hope you enjoy the game tonight thanks
Celtic City
[Applause]